[Music]  me  [Music]  one side of the building just fall  completely doesn't exist anymore  i had a friends over there i don't know  about them  sorry  i don't know about them i don't know if  they are alive  [Music]  the search and rescue team worked  throughout the night  and uh it was a very active scene  from above and below and uh  we also brought heavy machinery onto the  site  to assist with the operation and so we  are very very grateful that our  president has now  authorized fema support  [Music]  again search and rescue operations still  continue we have  heavy machinery on scene to start  pulling some of the superficial metal  from above  as we start looking for additional voids  from above  you